DAN GALPIN: Hi, and welcome
back to the Developer Show's
coverage at GDD India.
I'm Dan Galpin here
to talk about Instant
Apps with Lyla Fujiwara,
Android developer advocate.
LYLA FUJIWARA: So
basically, an Instant App
is an app where you
click on a link,
and you're immediately
taken into a native Android
experience.
DAN GALPIN: So
what do developers
need to do to turn their
app into an Instant App?
LYLA FUJIWARA: OK, so there's
a couple of major things
that they need to do.
The first is that you need
to have runtime permissions
implemented.
Now, if you're already targeting
M, you've already done this,
so that's great.
Another thing that
you need to do
is you need to
implement app links.
So of course, we're talking
about the experience
of clicking on the link
and getting into the app.
Well, that's exactly
what app links do,
so Instant Apps leverages that.
And finally, your app needs
to be under 4 megabytes
when it's coming
down to the device.
So that, in and of itself
seems a little bit worrisome,
because most apps are not
less than 4 megabytes.
But the way that Instant Apps
actually enables this is you
are able to split up your app
into separate feature modules
so you'll actually
make different modules
for the different experiences
that might be in your app,
and Instant Apps
will dynamically
download those for you
in 4 megabyte chunks.
DAN GALPIN: What are the biggest
challenges in getting apps
under 4 megabytes?
LYLA FUJIWARA: Right.
So even when you have
those feature modules,
there is the chance that
those will get larger
than 4 megabytes.
And honestly, the size of those
feature modules and the reason
that they might be
bloated is the same reason
that a normal
installable app might
be bloated, which is resources
and having potentially
extra libraries in there.
So if you think about it,
a library like Play Service
is 1.3 megabytes,
so already that's
getting you kind of close
to your 4 megabyte limit.
But you can do intelligent
things like only
take the parts of Play Services
that you actually need.
ProGuard is also very useful.
So for example, with
the support library,
that's like 2.4 megabytes.
If you implement
ProGuard, depending
on your usage with
the support library,
you can see up to 50% of
that cut out of the app.
And while you're doing this,
another thing to keep in mind
is that the APK Analyzer
is also incredibly useful.
So the APK Analyzer
is, of course,
included in Android Studio,
and lets you check your sizes
as you're doing your refactoring
and making things smaller.
So another useful thing to know
about are configuration APKs,
and you can actually configure
your [? gradle ?] files
to split up your APKs
into even smaller chunks.
Now, you can do this based on
three different dimensions.
So you can do it
based on language,
image density, and also what
hardware you're targeting.
And it uses all the
instant app technology,
so it's an instant
app specific thing,
and it's a pretty cool way to
get that shrinkage on your APK
size.
DAN GALPIN: So
where can developers
go to find more
out about building
Instant Apps and the Android
Studio refactoring tools.
LYLA FUJIWARA:
All right, well, I
would be remiss if I didn't
say go to the documentation.
So that's going to give you
kind of your baseline layer
of information about this.
I also think that Code Labs
are especially helpful.
There's a really great
Instant Apps Code Lab.
It actually takes
a kind of large app
that wasn't necessarily
built to be an Instant App,
and you go through the
practice of refactoring
it to become an Instant App.
Finally, there's a really
helpful blog post out there,
which we'll link which just
has a bunch of Instant App
specific strategies for again,
shrinking APK size down.
And that blog post
at the end of it,
it also links out to a bunch
of different partner blog posts
from companies
that have actually
gone through this
process where they
talk about the different
things that they did,
and give some sample
code, and just
talk about strategies for
what they did in their case.
DAN GALPIN: Thank you, Lyla.
LYLA FUJIWARA: Yeah, of course.
This was fun.
DAN GALPIN: Check
out the description
for links to Android
Instant Apps documentation.
Once again, I'm Dan Galpin
here with the Developer
Show at GDD India.